we have a voicemail number two one nine
two David P since face planting during
live calls several months ago the Kansas
troll has resurfaced okay here is the
Kansas troll with more anti-semitic
xenophobic racist stuff I caught him by
the way calling sam cedars show a couple
days ago the kansas troll called sam
cedar and started talking about inferior
intelligence among african-americans and
sam just ripped the guy apart and here
he is again the kansas troll for your
listening pleasure hi David uh I was
just watching the interview with the
former neo-nazi Frank mink so as we know
the entire FBI is running these taken ek
groups and I just had an observation
looking at Frank his features appear
almost identical to that of yours the
inward eye sockets the stereotypical
like Yiddish lips and chin and also the
downward large shaped nose which on the
end extrudes even further downwards the
nose nose you know and I'm not saying
that he wasn't a skinhead but he looks
like a total like kind of sigh off some
type of CIA Klan oh yeah it doesn't look
legit it seems like a fraud and I don't
think you should bring this guy on the
show again okay
presented without comment we've got a
great bonus show for you today a new
robot that can follow pedestrian traffic
rules new fathers are older than ever
and I was at a Billy Joel concert last
night almost elbowed in the head
numerous times I will talk about that
and more bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership